the more i look
into it this was squashed out of the
gate
by eco health nih
especially wh o and china itself so
the american public deserves it the
world deserves it with all the turmoil
that's been caused by it
senator mike braun earlier in the show
discussing the senate bill requiring the
biden administration
to declassify u.s intel on the origins
of coven let's bring in ari fleisher
former white house press secretary and a
fox news contributor
all right let me set this up a little
bit more with the wall street journal
headline today
on the editorial board the virus lab
theory's new credibility the evidence
catches up to fauci and other wuhan
covid
deniers going on to say mr biden is
trying to cover for his embarrassing
closure of the investigation
because the dam has finally broken on
the evidence that the virus may have
escaped from the wuhan institute of
virology
the shame is that it took so long
because the suspicious facts
have been apparent from the start it is
you know 16 months later
and we're actually spending our entire
week talking about something that a lot
of people brought up
about january 2020
and my only quibble with that editorial
is it said new evidence it's not
necessarily just the new piece of this
which was the revelation that three
scientists got hospitalized working at
the wuhan lab in november of 2019
but the evidence has been there all
along and here's what happened when
people
started to discuss the evidence about
could this have come from the lab
here's a very simple whiteboard for you
who was right and who was wrong
senator tom cotton in january 2020
raised that possibility he was on it
from the beginning
national review jim garrity a writer
there has been on this and writing very
thoughtful pieces from the beginning
secretary of state mike pompeo
he's talked about it he left office
talking about it
here's who is wrong the washington post
they said the theories that may have
begun in a lab or debunked the new york
times called those theories
fringe one science reporter there called
them racist
facebook as you just pointed out they
opposed the
debate of ideas free thinking they
suppressed them
about could this have begun in the lab
and finally china itself
china did everything in its power to lie
to deceive
and it's amazing how the mainstream
media went along
with china ari there's more uh you
mentioned a few there
here's um well here's a sample of what
we heard
throughout media outlets here roll this
number four
trump's decision to focus american spy
agencies on the government lab in wuhan
is nothing more
than an effort to deflect blame coming
up with a conspiracy theory
to try and romantic xenophobia
with respect to the chinese
has just as much factual support as
taking
clorox this is just another example of
the president trying to change the
narrative from his own failings donald
trump is still pushing the debunked
bunkum
despite his own intelligence community's
findings that that is simply not true
so if trump said it or did it do the
opposite ari
yeah this is just so terrible it's
anti-evidence anti-science
anti-intellect all in the service of get
trump politics
and we americans have got to open up our
eyes if there is truth if there is
evidence that needs to be pursued
but what happens too often with the
critics of donald trump and the
mainstream media they think if it
derives from the right it must be wrong
and we are doing this nation a terrible
disservice by not having free and honest
debates anymore
the idea that it could have come from a
lab always made
sense no one really credible was
suggesting that it was done on purpose
by china to get the world
but did it leak from the lab 3 million
dead and were not willing to take a hard
look at what china's role was in this
we better now take a real hard open look
release the intelligence at what china's
role was this
and the chips need to fall wherever they
may because 3 million people have died
and the world was in turmoil
why don't we deserve to know
just quickly ari president biden has
asked for a response from the indel
community in another 90 days
at that point do you think that they
will be transparent
well china will never be transparent
just like the soviet union covered up
chernobyl china is going to cover up
whatever
happened in that lab but i don't know
why it takes 90 days
this happened more than a year ago right
the intelligence community already knows
these answers they have the info they're
going to get i don't think there's much
more they need to get release it
yeah ari fleischer we'll talk again very
soon thanks